9 octobre 80 la peine de mort est abolie
en france un engagement de la gauche qui
allait à l'encontre de la majorité des
français à l'époque avant d'en parler
avec robert badinter
retour sur une des affaires qui a
provoqué le débat dans les années 70
l'exécution de crise en ranucci alors
que le doute sur sa culpabilité n'a
jamais été levé
marité recours tellement le dossier est
resté sur le bureau de m le forsonney
pourtant la sphère date de 1974 l'avocat
avait alors 25 ans ranucci était son
premier client été commis d'office comme
personne ne voulait assurer sa défense
il fallait bien que quelqu'un s'y colle
donc le sort est tombé sur moi j'ai
accepté la défense
un matin du mois de juin il y à 27 ans
la cité sainte agnès à marseille une
petite fille marie dolorès rambla est
enlevée par un homme décrit par deux
témoins comme étant jeune brun grand et
mince
une heure plus tard un automobiliste
brune un stop à la sortie de marseille
le conducteur percute un autre véhicule
avant de s'enfuir deux témoins le
prennent en chasse relève son numéro
d'immatriculation avant de le voir
partir dans ces forêts un paquet
volumineux sous le bras le soir même
christian ranucci est arrêté après 18
heures d'interrogatoire il avoue
l'enlèvement et le meurtre de marie
dolorès indique même où il a caché
l'armé du crime
les charges sont accablantes mais quinze
jours plus tard l'homme revient sur ses
aveux il accuse la police de l'avoir
obligé à parler
le 10 mars 76 christian ranucci et
condamné à mort à l'énoncé de la
sentence le public applaudit pourtant le
dossier présente des failles avec
notamment le mystère du pull over rouge
retrouvé sur les lieux du crime
après l'avoir flairer les chiens sont
allés jusqu'au corps de la petite fille
c'est prouvé ce pull n'appartenait pas à
christian ranucci le doute ne profitera
pas à l'accusé valéry giscard d'estaing
refuse à grasse le 28 juillet christian
ranucci décapité on s'est retrouvés à la
maison d'arrêt à 4 heures du matin où il
y avait pour éviter de faire du bruit et
de prévenir le reste de la maison grise
à vincennes et couvertures par terre
pour marche dans le silence j'avais une
lettre de sa mère
je lui vois c'est le dernier regard que
j'ai eus drame chez mon très cher enfant
je t'écris cette carte que tu es avocat
te donneront en caquetá grâce soit
refusé tu es innocent et tu as été un
bon fils crie son innocence soit
courageux pense à moi je t'embrasse fort
ta maman
moi j'ai pas de peine à reconnaître que
j'ai pas regardé sa guillotine ce sont
des bruits c'est assez le bruit l'espèce
de joux qui descend claque comme ça sur
la tête le boyau plutôt évolué jets
d'eau alors voilà les souvenirs qu'on
garde de ça sont des bruits 25 ans plus
tard un autre homme n'a pas oublié ce
matin du 28 juillet 1976
nous avons rencontré pierre semblât le
père de la petite fille assassinée
maintenant tous les criminels de ta
fille il est plus d'un coupé la tête
alors là ils étaient soulagés il faut
maintenant il a tué ma fille il y aura
plus personne
voilà c'est pas la tête à chaque fois
dans des affaires louches il chez capcom
pas la ville a fait la route gestion ou
compagnon caméra temps avec eux et je
moi je crois que c'est ma fille la
coupable de la mort d'un cheval pour
prendre mon p g me rapporter 25 ans plus
tard mettre le forsonney s'interroge
toujours qu'ils étaient réellement
responsable de cette sentence de mort
quelqu'un meurt mais la responsabilité
de cette mort est à la fois collective
diluée et insaisissable est ce que c'est
la faute de l'avocat qui a mal défendu
est ce que c'est la faute de la oca
général qui a requis est ce que c'est la
faute du juge qui a mal jugé est-ce que
c'est faux de l'opinion publique
soyez des fusées qui avoue oui enfin
c'est cette si vous me demandez un
souvenir bon jeu j'en tire pas ton
plusieurs rouge dit voilà c'est ça qui
est frappant à trois reprises depuis
l'exécution de christian ranucci cet
avocat a déposé une requête en révision
du procès à trois reprises
la justice française l'a déboutée